we just got a brand-new Nintendo Direct
today all about pokemon sword and shield
Kali you're our pokemon expert what is
the biggest thing that stood out to you
well if you're talking about biggest we
can talk about Dyna maxing the thing
that makes Pokemon giant so Dyna maxing
is a new battle mechanic kind of like a
hybrid of mega evolution and Z moves in
some ways so you can only use it once
per battle it only lasts three turns
right yes and it makes your Pokemon huge
like kaiju huge and increases power and
stuff like that you also have moves
called max moves which are like powerful
versions of the moves your Pokemon
already have apparently that can vary
based on what those existing moves were
so there's elements of strategy it seems
to like when you choose to Dynomax which
pokémon you Dynomax with your opponent
can Dynomax battling Gym Leaders they'll
be able to do this yeah it looks like
the new gym stadiums are definitely
built for these Dyna maxing Pokemon yeah
the city the stadiums are huge and
there's people in the crowds and they
said when when a Pokemon dynamaxx is the
crowd will go crazy yeah there's also
Dynomax Pokemon that feed into another
cool mechanic which is raid battles so
you can partner up this is one of the
multiplayer features you can team up
with up to four people if you don't have
four people they'll like autofill with
support trainers is my understanding and
you take on a Dyna maxed wild Pokemon
yeah it's called a max raid yeah and you
apparently want to bring your best
Pokemon into that battle and then if you
beat them you'll get the opportunity to
catch kind of like Pokemon go yeah
except you have a giant pokéball that
you throw these giant Pokemon yes makes
sense that does make sense
like with let's go they're bringing in
elements of Pokemon go and the things
people like about Pokemon go without
making it just exactly go there's even
some it looks like some influences from
Pokemon let's go we saw the wild area
which is basically seems like an open
area almost like a breath of the wild
esque you can control the camera you can
explore different reads or different
areas of Guillard that have seems like
different weather different kinds of
Pokemon you can catch and the Pokemon
are kind of just wandering around in the
wild yeah so the wild area seems like a
catch-all term for just the air
like the expanse of nature in between
cities so you can go to like obviously
there will be like grassland and
mountains and different biomes and yet
depending on the weather depending on
where you are you'll encounter different
Pokemon those r8 battles happen in the
wild area and yeah you see Pokemon
wandering around just like and let's go
the thing that was confusing from
watching the trailer was that it's not
exactly clear if all the battles are
like opted in like in let's go where you
approach the one or if there are there
is some element of random encounter but
from what I can tell it seems like
random encounters are mostly out and
even in the tall grass you see like an
exclamation point before entering a
battle but even that you have to
approach the exclamation point yeah my
guess is the areas where you can control
the camera that is where you'll see the
Pokemon wandering out in the wild but in
the ones you can't there might be light
random encounters maybe like the the
exclamation point in grass that you can
walk up to at least from what I can tell
it seems like you don't know what
Pokemon you're gonna get in those
encounters and it's not just gonna like
happen to you you yeah what'll be
interesting is caves whether or not
caves will zubats will randomly attack
you yeah I don't know how they're they
wouldn't be able to fit new bats and the
bigger Pokemon like how are you gonna
fit onyx and the way that mine shaft
works you know yeah
um I actually think this is a cool
change I like that I'll be able to see
Pokemon the overworld I think that the
wild area looks really open-world like
and really big even like going in the
water you can see Pokemon the water you
see evolved forms of things yeah that
was one thing that you saw a lot of and
let's go you'd see Charizard is flying
around for example in this you see
melodic just swimming around which has
typically been known as a Pokemon that's
very difficult to get you have to get a
phoebus which is hard to get and this is
like you have to like click on a certain
tile or you used to have to go to a
certain tile and it was random you
didn't know what tile it was until you
cut a few baths and even then you only
had a certain chance that's refreshing
have you thought that because I love a
lot excellent my favorite another
interesting thing is how you traverse
those areas too it seems like the bike
is back that's something that wasn't and
let's go which was surprising because
that was in red and blue and it also
wasn't in Sun and Moon because you had
rideshare II earn my ride sharing will
actually get to that later with with the
new Edgar Allan Poe bird yeah
it seems like your bike will play a huge
role in that there's that one image of
there's balloons on the side of the bike
so it looks like that almost takes the
place of surf there's another screenshot
with bikes that sparks are coming out of
the wheels not entirely sure what that's
for
it's a really really brief look the the
bike stuff is really brief in the
trailer and I missed it the first time I
watched it but yeah I really liked ride
Pokemon I liked the freedom I like that
that makes more sense within the world
of Pokemon and it seems like there's a
blend of your bike and a right Pokemon
yeah but but maybe not in the same sense
as we saw the moon because it sounds
like that one Pokemon whose name I'm
forgetting core of a knight it kind of
seems like Korver Knight acts as your
fly like once you visit a city you can
go find him in that city and find that
bird in that city you can fly to a
different city that you've already been
to so yeah I'm curious how those other
abilities will work like cut or or a
strength or something like I I hope
they're gone let's get to the new
Pokemon then we're talking about it I
really like the designs of this
generation so far I think you know
people complain about designs from all
generations but these are looking pretty
good the first one is Lulu the it's a
sheep Pokemon I am curious about what
type it is we already have an electric
sheep I think it's normal but I like it
I like my design a whole lot then
there's gossip floor the flowering
Pokemon it looks definitely grass and we
also see that with a grass-type gym
leader which we'll get to in a second
that evolves into Elda goths which is
the same but with like a giant thing on
its head yeah there's also dreadnought
which is the bite Pokemon I liked I
think that's my favorite one of the ones
that they've shown off yeah happy with
that
then there's court of night like we
mentioned the flying-type pokémon that
one probably Corvin night it's got to be
steel maybe I think it's just based on
like the Ravens and the Tower of London
yeah so we also got a look at the new
legendaries there's a Shion the sword
legendary and ins amaz enta the shield
legendary and they look very similar
except for the you know one has a sword
in its mouth and one has got a shield
beer shield beard well which one do you
think you'll pick I really like the
sword one but I think everyone's gonna
like the sword one and you know I don't
want to I don't
sheep unless it's Lulu so I think the
interesting thing about these two
legendaries is that most Pokemon games
don't have legendaries that are like
swaps of each other or super similar
like the Latios and latias would be the
one that jumps out to me those weren't
even like the mascot yeah yeah and then
finally we got info on the characters in
the story the only thing that I thought
was weird was that they announced the
champion I feel like typically they wait
until like that's always like the reveal
the damn champion is like someone we've
been talking to you the whole team yeah
and this time there which I'm kind of
okay with because those twists were
always like yeah whatever I do want to
note that we got like gallery region
culture and that would be like Pokemon
battles are a really big deal that's why
the stadiums are in addition to having a
room for those giant Pokemon yeah
like soccer football and then Pokemon
also work alongside people in the
gallery Jeff yeah there's really why not
run around I think like what do you want
to counter I don't think that's like
unique I think a lot of games have that
but this is the one where it's most
explicitly stated like yeah Pokemon are
part of the economy the one red flag
that I know this was my low I don't like
my low at all the grass type yeah I
don't like him why he's a buff man with
a child's head I don't and that's
everything we noticed in the Pokemon
Nintendo Direct if there's anything we
missed please let us know in the
comments below and this comes out
November 15 2019 until next time
you
[Music]